you start therapy next week right that's
what i had heard and that you chose your
therapist
because she was hot i i get really like
perfectionistic about which one i'm
gonna pick so i finally said you know
i'll just
she has a nice face so she'll be nice to
talk to on on
zoom he's gonna get somebody to date him
one way or another
they think they're giving him therapy
he's on a date
you know what i love uh benji puppet
we've made a benji puppet and then of
course in typical benji fashion he grew
a beard so now
you guys don't look alike he finally got
a puppet
i might be able to fix that i'm working
on making some adjustments
on my facial hair one of the guys who
writes on the show lovely guy mike
traynor said to me
benji has been very hostile lately
hostile yeah that's what he
said i'm worried about him probably more
than anyone else on staff
he really snaps at people and yes
i think you're you're a contrarian by
nature which can be interesting and i
like talking to you
but yeah sometimes being contrarian is
just ridiculous and it gets you into
ridiculous arguments that make no sense
in some ways i'd rather you think i'm
contrarian i'm being sincere and you
guys think that
i'm making up things i just feel for
that poor woman he's gonna
but the psychiatrist be so she already
he's gonna listen to him for an hour
i guarantee you that that psychiatrist
will
quit being a psychiatrist after she has
five sessions with this [ __ ] maniac
i'm telling her first appointment and
she said i i can't be here next week
already his psychiatrist is canceling
sessions
this is something part of the reason why
people think he's hostile
is someone cracked a joke yesterday when
you were talking about
brad and george couldn't have a kid and
they were thinking about adopting and
somebody said you know you should adopt
benji
and benji got real it was richard he got
really mad at them he's like i love my
parents that's a horrible thing to say
and i believe that you you carried on
after the show
and you made richard apologize to you i
i never i've never liked when people say
i want someone else to adopt
you because i do benji i don't think
anyone was just joking
all right all right anyway hey good
talking to you
and uh we know how you are now now we
know how you
are somebody mark this day on the
calendar and make sure we don't do that
again for another three months
three months six months i mean is it
weird that benji hired a therapist and
she already canceled appointments
i mean that's i've never heard